we're talking about race we're talking
about racism okay so the problem I'm not
racist how am I a part of the problem
because I would imagine at some pay at
some point you've enabled some sort of
racism I'm asking that a subject because
I think I've been in situations where
I've heard someone or something been
said and I haven't addressed it like I
should okay I'll admit that because to
me they're a bit thick right they are
thick not a bit so I know I'm arguing
the stupid do you see what I mean that's
their opinion but I appreciate that is
the problem because I should be more
vocal and say oh yeah what the [__] you
talking about instead of just ignoring
it
foreign